a fragmentary localism where you have
one level of loyalty to your local
community and the next level up is the
whole planet and there's nothing in
between no state no nation you know just
planetary consciousness and a and a
community conscious
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
we have speed
[Music]
well Viktor tell me what's the most
interesting idea that you've encountered
here in Prague has there been anything
stunning
yeah probably yes I want to establish
new organization in Russia when I'm just
coming to Russia and I want to do new
organization in Russia it's Russian
transpersonal Center and the most
interesting idea which came to me here
was just a special way how that these
organizations must must do must function
function right and I cannot just
formulate I cannot define this idea
directed but it's definitely will be a
new ways to connect new ways to concern
goals of these organizations
there is no boundaries real boundaries
between assets like axiom and this is
probably the basis of on which we can
establish we can grow that the way of
functioning these kind of organizations
well so you feel that these
transpersonal ideas could have an impact
in Russia as it undergoes whatever
social evolution it's going to undergo
mm-hmm yeah also it doesn't matter will
everybody and accept this kind of
functioning this kind of ideas no matter
accept or not but anyway this idea will
be and it will be real because it's like
general it's more close to general way
of all nations so I think so I thought
so you mean it's almost explicit in the
order of things yeah I agree
so some kind of ever-present organic
order is emerging yeah this was why I
thought it was interesting that Denmark
voted against the AC because I think
European federalism is the old style of
government and that fragmentary localism
where you have one level of loyalty to
your local community and the next level
up is the whole planet and there's
nothing in between no state no nation
you know just planetary consciousness
and a community country yeah because on
our biological level we have to solve
our problems which grows up from our ego
and this is the main point of our
difficulties the environment yeah yes
but also on social level that is
probably the most problem is egos of
organization egos of countries of states
and probably if we solve this kind of
connections so institutional it will be
more more appropriate for our life flex
as social objects absolutely
do you know Franco Delisle no just
Franco did a lot of in fact the only
research allowed on LSD in the United
States and what in the late 70s early
80s and was that it am I am angry well
and that makes never get the funding but
it was significant
it was protocol that took several years
to develop together by the FDA involved
after ten sessions Corrales days in
standard dose of 400 micrograms new one
25 a hotel the other study was more open
and every cancer patients where we were
trying to change the research tree
very 8 for the experience rather than
the drug people could have a certain
type of experience
so we want these patients as their own
controls and control for the experience
when the experience to phrase and it was
there wasn't I always felt this is not a
drug reaction
it's a nice matter of I know just given
the drug is an experience that resulted
from demonstration rugged how correlated
with positive results vice versa
somebody's work to activate some jaws of
trauma and quite completed you might
expect them to be depressed for a couple
examples until they could get back in
and completed so it would be mistake to
say let's just give these dosage and
then measure the effect because he
wasn't a question of those he was the
question of the nature of the experience
there was activated
it's that affected a personality so we
were able to do that with the
consultations that have
to use the application so very
controlled a what we call the peak
experience pinky it was physicians at
16% concluded that the peak experience
there was a way than to say okay if
worth 60% where you're different because
of what you shutting the MMPI scale of
anxiety and depression before and after
and in fact it was measurable the people
who had a peak experience there such a
psychometric forcing this much
and the next face then was to me was
okay if you don't get a peak experience
then can you get me if you continue
treatment because there's a whole
process here dealing with you know the
drug is just icky but it's opening the
door the similar process they couldn't
fire return and it's conceivable
very well that if people were not
Pickers to begin with making worth to be
figures in future sessions or that
initial figures to become more robust
speakers with continued treatment so
that the initial results but then
required a lot more sessions because I
think
take a soul I guess so
individual AmeriCorps between 15 and 18
so they that's essentially where the
researcher
stalls because she was very different to
give you indications so do you get the
feeling that it's opening up again
because of these things going on in
Switzerland and Strassman stuff in New
Mexico there's a need for more there are
a lot of petitions that we cannot effect
very well today so everybody knows you
know in some message wildlife yeah they
make it better for a while than to lose
it and it's sort of like you know trying
to plug the holes rot and some point you
have to say you know maybe we can
restructure that we both rather than
people putting all this energy and
there's tremendous effort there's social
workers oh it's a whole social system
trying to sort of put scaffolds to hold
these people to a level of function
where diminutive - so you're saying for
the worst reasons we may finally get
good social source we do need it you see
the fact is that we need something a bit
more effected in what we have now what
point will the profession say
we have to look into research that's
already been documented to look for what
might be a way out of this dilemma
because you know economically society's
been drained everything right now hiding
and any person has to be hospitalized is
coming for thousands guys just everybody
it's a physical examination again
laboratory work they get the activity
therapist evaluates them the social
worker evaluates a psychiatrist or are
you 18 so it doesn't matter to come in
for two days or it's the 20th time the
thirtieth time they'll have still to say
and that's what straining the system
so we have to find ways to prevent this
means pharmacology is due for some kind
of a mini renaissance probably or a
cyclist because now it's still I think
it's the face where they're trying to
look for the better chorus in the
veterans of depression and that's okay
but it's going to be a number of people
that are functionally fairly well but
you're you're talking about psychedelic
we assisted therapy which is different
which would be to treat the personality
right to treat the person now when you
get to treating the personality I think
more or less people are conceding that
there is no actual way to treat advising
hospital money to hospitalize the
patient suffering character any of their
proposition
we have evidence from the work done at
the center with ever steamy this very
severe character disorders some meet
with the effect of the drug could begin
to make sense of why they develop their
personality that developed based on the
experience that they had growing up and
and now you have a patient who says I
could see why you know I remember one
case what it says it was called the
black sheep for the family well in fact
it did become the course and then but
they can begin to make a connection that
it's not in there sleeping I think the
country thesaurus doesn't know why
they're doing what they're doing why
they're motivated to do certain things
only where there are you needed from
yourself
and if you try to do therapy with them
they're our future
because they know that you care
verbally gala to induce them to have
anything that it's very meaningful which
these are the frequently on show up for
a point and because they did and the
same person if we can induce them to
have a real therapeutic session
yeah right if you say I'll see you
Monday they they'll be there because now
they know there is a history in there is
a way that I'm doing so it's just a
matter of reaching and and so that's the
important thing do you think there's a
lot of said a lot of issues for instance
when you get involved with
you know psychopathy of criminality
they get sending to institution when
were clear
not guilty for reason of insanity
at this stage of the game it's very
understanding there is no real reason to
release them because there's no way that
any psychiatrist could say they're now
cowardice for arson and I can guarantee
you that it won't do it you see that in
and we're still doing it but I don't
think there is a real basis that we're
sort of saying this person wasn't really
that criminal and we can take a chance
on this person again now if you had a
way of really solving followed any
assigning then you have any other circum
solid to say I think this person is okay
Jack I can feel Jack getting nervous but
this is good it is good okay thank you
I think you should go for a one other if
I am good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]